twice
down goes into
near the logo
near the logo up against it lebron
drains the three it was almost at mid
court as the
shot clock was just about out as he just
takes his time look how easy he makes
that look
he loses it forgot the basketball look
at this pass intended for lebron he's
got it
throw it down king oh you said it's his
19th year what a pass by dj too to lead
him perfectly
look at this play look at the lead and
look at lebron how's he going to finish
it
19 years in the league and a lot of
these opportunities he still has the
hops terrific scoring balance for the
rockets all their young guys
christian wood has a double double that
gets broken up
that was the right play to make lebron
had another little elbow
[Applause]
don't let that go in
are they calling that
turnover lakers they're 12. all of a
sudden with a burst of speed chased down
by lebron blocked by james look at
lebron with the look at that bounce pass
as wayne ellington
cut baseline and gets to easy deuce
[Music]
graduated high school the same year he's
young and he shows it on that slam yeah
my goodness trying to get to the rim so
it's been feaster famine for rush so far
at the other
blocked by james
on the chase down and he does the
mutombo
he's not going to give up look at this
play where he just comes out of nowhere
and i mean he hits it hard a little
softer and it might have been kept in
play and the lakers had an opportunity
to take it and go the other way
[Applause]
james way outside that's the three
long distance from lebron james
[Applause]
they're just scoring at will right now
overall
lebron
bring it right back with authority and
dwight is four rebounds closer to the
top ten lebron
behind the head throw it down reverse
dunk on the beautiful live in the jam
come on do the rest and he did the rest
look at that didn't even have to look
he said to my backs to the basket no
problem i'm up high enough i know where
it is throws it down and the crowd loved
every minute of it westbrook drive loops
it
ariza with the shot clock winding down
gives it up westbrook call fake no look
slam down lebron james a little extra
sauce and a technical foul
westbrook with the penetration excellent
cut by lbj and then the back side and
he's saying right that he did get hit
that was an impressive defensive play
he's got a couple like good blocks today
james season opening drives inside and
the flush
38 for james
baldwell pope
now to poisons good play by ross double
teaming shoveled at the lebron here he
comes lebron james
throw it down
[Music]
[Applause]
lebron james to the hoop and there he is
and then there was one
kareem abdul-jabbar and lebron james 1-2
all-time in the nba scoring at home
against the pelicans short awesome
was there to get the fresh 14 for the
lakers lebron
[Applause]
just
hammers it
[Applause]
[Music]
got another one
lebron drains another one
yes sir
letting the pacer fans know it they've
been on him a little bit tonight
and his play
look at him calling for it reg
and he is from background let's do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fitting that the king would come home
to his castle yes sir
and say
yes sir
night night
game-winning shot